Suda for the biggest crossover ever
we've got your backs flexes on Infinite
Earths The CW's crossover event begins
Sunday December 8 presented by boost
mobile the switch that gives you more
all right tomorrow morning 9 o'clock
tunnels bringing all fantasy theme why
should we do that cuz I know how to say
it Barry Allen
[Music]
you must be the monitor how do you know
it has no human would actually wear
something so ridiculous you ate for the
world you lost and ibises the power to
restore it you can bring back where's
the recovery of your universe will
require a single task
what kind of task
you must be trade Oliver Queen
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my crisis on Infinite Earths
teaser video they dropped the first look
there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs in
here I'll explain what's going on and
why some of these villains are showing
up in these so we'll do a new round of
that flash ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite moment from the teaser on
the video there's a couple scenes from
the last episode's teasing crisis stuff
so I added that to this I'll talk about
those in a second but first we'll talk
about the crisis footage so first you
see a version of the monitor on another
world that looks like the monitor but he
doesn't have the muttonchops so either
it's a younger version of the monitor
earlier in the timeline or it's someone
like the anti-monitor because during the
original comic book crisis there was
only one monitor for the entire
multiverse the positive matter
multiverse and then one anti monitor for
the antimatter universe so what might be
happening here is they just used the
Waverider to travel back in time to a
different period and talk to him and
that's why he doesn't have the
muttonchops
remember the legends will be
participating and be a huge part of the
crossover this year for those of you
that wondered whether or not they were
going to be around because they skipped
last year they even made a joke about
that during last season the legends we
should have participated in the
crossover you might notice some
interesting additions to the group shot
here though from left to right we have
martian manhunter about time he had a
bigger role in the crossover he is one
of the most powerful characters that
they have in the arrowverse and they
barely ever use them during the team-ups
sarah standing here like i said a
legends gonna be a big part of the
crossover again this year the first
episode of legends new season is
actually going to be the crossover but
that's not happening till January so
I'll explain the schedule because
there's gonna be two parts to the
crossover three episodes in December and
then they go on break for a couple weeks
then they come back at the end of
January and they have the last two
episodes it's arrow than legends of
tomorrow is pulling up the anchor but
that will be the first episode of their
brand new season and they're taking
arrows time slot after arrows series
finale which actually I think it's a
little bit after the crossover then you
have Barry and Cara both in their brand
new suits they both got brand new gear
this year nice and shiny Barry got the
chin back but it's also a top-to-bottom
redesign with a completely new material
that's way more breathable in real life
way more comfortable for Grant Gustin to
walk around in and easier to get in and
out of when he needs to but they also
gave him way more
comic-book accurate earpieces that are
flared out just a little bit bigger than
the ones he's had in the past biggest
difference in Supergirl suit is that she
ditched the skirt and got the pants so
her costume looks much more like Earth
38 Superman's costume Supergirl has worn
pants in the comics before but I don't
remember what their reason for doing
that on the TV show is her new costume
works a lot like Tony Stark's Avengers
end game at Avengers infinity war
costumes with the nanobots forming the
suit around him at will or say like
black panthers vibranium suit she
doesn't have to step into the pants one
leg at a time like Stephen Amell when
he's putting on his arrow pants for the
costume she just wills it to form around
her when she needs it quick reminder
because they haven't done a scene in a
while but Barry is still using the flash
ring he's been using it since the
beginning of season 5 but it costs a lot
of money to do the special effects for
that so that's why you don't see them
doing a version of this scene every
single time he puts the suit on then
moving down the line a really big
addition to the team lex luthor from
earth 38 played by Jon Cryer if you
didn't watch Supergirl last season he
actually played Lenny Luthor during
Superman for the quest for peace way
back when he was a character they
created for the movie just to be a lex
luthor's punk-rock nephew they've joked
about it a few times on the show but
they had Supergirl kill him at the end
of last season and in a post-credits
scene during the finale the monitor
shows up in a resurrects him saying that
he has some special purpose in the fight
to come
the people that the monitor is
collecting he's calling Paragons the
special people that will defend the
multiverse against the anti-monitor it's
sort of like Goku and the universe 7
team during Dragon Ball super universe
survival saga you get a bunch of your
friends together to win a battle for the
fate of the universe
some of them villains so like Lex Luthor
for instance would be their Frieza the
person who's gonna double-cross them the
first chance he gets but we'll help them
out along the way if you are a big comic
book crisis fan you will remember though
that Lex Luthor was an important
character during that but it was
actually an alternate universe version
called Alexander Luthor from earth 3
when that crisis broke out he was a baby
they aged him rapidly to adulthood and
helped him gain special powers over
antimatter the monitor wound up dying he
took his place as team leader for all
the heroes as they faced the
anti-monitor
so we wound up being a really important
but really good character during that
event later he wound up double-crossing
then during Infinite Crisis and became
the villain of that event very Lex
Luthor twist you pretend to help people
out but then you ultimately double-cross
them standing next to him you'll notice
asura cow from Supernatural he's playing
the Ryan Choi Adam starting this season
on legends of tomorrow and he'll debut
during the crossover
he's also the person you may remember
from last season to the flash that made
Barry's flash rings but in the future so
he'll continue to be important to the
other characters on the other TV shows
making technology for them the whole
reason they're adding him is because
Brandon Roth who normally plays Ray
Palmer Adam is leaving legends of
tomorrow this season so they need a
replacement to take the mantle and Ryan
Choi was just the next version of the
atom to take the mantle in the comics so
it makes sense that you would introduce
him at some point
Brandon Roth is playing both kingdom
comes Superman during the crossover and
Ray Palmer Adam so you've seen both
pictures of them during different scenes
it makes sense there would be a moment
with them acknowledging that they both
look very much alike like wow your
version of Superman but somehow you're
different you're Clark Kent from Krypton
and I'm a normal human from Planet Earth
yet somehow we have the exact same face
even though we're calling him Kingdom
Come Superman because that's the costume
that he's wearing from the comics he's
playing a version of his Superman from
Superman Returns so because that was a
sequel movie - Superman - with Richard
Donner and Christopher
it's sort of implying that Christopher
Reeves Superman eventually became
Kingdom Come Superman here's some fanart
of what that would look like had
Christopher Reeve survived to
present-day early speculation to they
might do a version of supergirls death
from comic book crisis but maybe they'll
kill off Kingdom Come Superman and he'll
be the one that they're holding here
sacrificing himself for the group then
you have bat woman pretty
self-explanatory then you have the first
scene of Black Lightning during the
crossover that we've seen just in the
middle of a fight of course he's going
to participate in the Waverider scenes
but it's really hard to tell what else
he'll be doing so whatever he's doing it
sounds like it's gonna be fun but he
won't be around for every single episode
of the crossover then the scene of bat
woman Oliver and Mia
walking through the rubble in the middle
of some big fight that they're having we
get the brand-new crisis on Infinite
Earths intro logo they always make a
custom one for each of the different
crossovers year-to-year but the letters
in the footage within them don't
correspond to the actual episode order
so quick reminder crossover starts
Sunday December 8th with Supergirl
episode 9 Batwoman is episode 2 the
Flash's episode 3 then they go on break
for a couple weeks and come back for the
second half yes I have heard the rumor
about Tom Welling Superman from
Smallville only being in a very few
short scenes during the crossover I'm
assuming it's during the first Supergirl
episode since most Superman related
things happen on Supergirl and because
this scene takes place with earth 38
Superman in his Lois Lane on the Kent
farm it just a question of which can't
farm are they gonna be on Smallville's
earth are they gonna be on earth 38 when
this is happening the other really big
news literal and metaphorical big news
is that they cast The Spectre character
from the comics but it's unclear what
his role is going to be during the TV
crossover he had a big role during
comic-book crisis but I don't know if
they're gonna do the same thing with him
during the TV show and even though we
haven't seen any footage of
reverse-flash recently reverse-flash
will also be a big part of the crossover
- but because Tom Cavanagh is playing a
couple different characters it's hard to
say which episodes he's going to be in
next crisis
[Music]
but everybody let me know in the
comments what are you most excited about
if you have any big questions there'll
be more bigger trailers with more crisis
footage dropping in the next couple of
weeks
there is no episode of the flash this
week what's happening tomorrow if you
didn't see Disney Plus is launching and
the first episode of the mandalorian
I'll be doing a video for that so
that'll be my Tuesday video and a brand
new Rick and Morty episode 2 trailer as
long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you see those videos when I post
them everybody click here for my Rick
and Morty season 4 episode 1 video and
click here for my last big flash crisis
on Infinite Earths video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]